welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the
release of dr. sleep taking us back to
the world of the shining I thought it
was the perfect time to break down the
big villain of the piece Rose the hat
and her group of followers the true not
as chosen by you were going to be
covering what we know about the group
their abilities and the differences in
their depiction from the book and the
film now there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the movie yet and don't want
anything ruined then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of Rose the hat and the
true knot okay so the film dr. sleep
actually spans a great distance of time
beginning just after the events of the
shining in the early 1980s and running
all the way up to modern day whilst we
primarily focus on Danny Torrance a
strong psychic there also exists the
true knot we witness operating from the
1980s to present we watch as danny grows
older his life torn apart by alcoholism
whilst the true not remain ageless due
to the fact that they are able to take
the life force or as they call it steam
from psychics the group are basically
vampires that live a nomadic lifestyle
moving from state to state in a convoy
preying on the weak and unsuspecting
because of this they have attained a
certain kind of immortality that keeps
them immune to most natural causes
though they are able to be killed
through more conventional methods what
doctors sleep oils down to and portrays
and both its protagonist Danny and the
antagonists the true not is a battle
with addiction
Danny similar to his father is an
alcoholic that is neglectful less caring
of others and because of this elites to
the death of an infant after its mother
overdoses Danny is really torn apart by
this and the guilt that he feels over
this act causes him to up sticks and
start a new life where he will not allow
his demons to take over him mirroring
this the true Nauta addicts too addicted
to steam but unlike Danny they do not
take any responsibility for the pain
that they inflict and thus they operate
almost with a sense of Glee - causing
the deaths of children but reveling in
it instead of being disgusted this is
the main conflict of doctors sleep and
the entire storyline is about Danny
trying to protect a chair
from succumbing to the addiction of
others that do not possess the same
morality that he does there's a pivotal
moment and dr. sleep in which they have
the choice between their addiction and
doing the right thing Danny is offered a
drink and he turns it down thus putting
his demons to rest and going on to do
the right thing that has an overall
positive outcome juxtaposing this after
the true 'no are wiped out just leaving
Rose by herself she has the option to
her Abrego but her greed and craving for
steam get the better of her and this
ultimately leads to her downfall the
true not themselves are fascinating and
they have a long storied history and way
of life that makes them one of the most
unique horror creations in all of
Stephen King's back catalogue when
describing themselves during one of
their many rituals throughout the work
they state we are the true not and we
endure we are the chosen ones
we are the fortunate ones what is tide
cannot be untied here is a woman will
she join us will she tie her life to our
life this pretty much sums up their
entire belief system and mindset the
true not believed themselves to be above
all closely knit group that operated
almost as a hive mind through their
psychic link they justify the atrocities
that they carry out because it keeps the
group as one and thus there is a shared
lack of morality that empowers them to
go on and carry out more depraved acts
some of the members of the group have
lives which span millennia and though
there has never been a specific date
ever set for when they first started out
in the film there is lip service paid to
the fact that they have existed
throughout the Middle Ages and even so
far back as the Roman Empire because of
this they have not built natural
immunities towards modern day diseases
and in the original source material the
majority of them are wiped out after one
of the members of the group catches
measles from feasting on a boy with a
disease he passes this on to the camp
who slowly began to succumb to the
disease and die from it this differs
from the film adaptation in which they
are lured into an ambush
after Danny and his friend Billy use
Abra is bait to draw them out and then
shoot them from vantage points with
sniper rifles both situations though
eventually lead to Rose being the sole
survivor now in the book the true knot
are made up of six members
and though this differs slightly for the
film adaptation most notably in their
names I thought I'd stick to the main
source material and the way that they
are described in it I'll get to Rosa
last as I wanted to cover here more in
depth but the second in command is named
crow daddy he is Rosa's lover and
operates with extreme loyalty crow
daddy's real name is Henry Rothman and
whilst he does not possess the psychic
powers of the other members he is able
to track people possessing the ability
to shine in the film he dies due to his
arrogance and he does not wear a seat
belt which allows Danny who is
possessing Abra at the time to kill him
in a car accident
grandpa flick is the next in line and he
is the eldest of the group early on in
the storyline he dies and this makes the
group worried that their days are too
numbered and thus they desperately
attempt to get more steam which makes
them set their sights on Abra snake by
Andy is up next
and in dr. sleep we see the recruitment
process of the true not mainly through
her eyes
Andy is known as a pusher and someone
that can will people into doing her
bidding through commands that she tells
them vocally in the film she performs
this on Billy who she wills into killing
himself and we see in the movie that
very few are actually immune to her
before her recruitment Andy gained her
nickname for luring child predators on
dates with her putting them to sleep and
then carving a snakebite like scars into
their cheeks in the source material at
due to her dislike of men which was
caused by the abuse of her father del
Thunder her as a child she becomes a
lesbian and is in a relationship with
our next member silence sorry silence
sorry gains her name due to a
self-consciousness about her speech
impediment however this also plays into
the fact that she has the ability to
move in complete silence were not being
looked at this allows her to sneak up on
prey without alerting them and she's a
very terrifying foe lastly is Barry
Smith who is pretty much the one that
brings all of the true not to their
eventual fate Barry ends up contracting
the measles and thus the group all end
up dead due to the disease in the book
he's white but gains a very bad nickname
due to his slanted eyes which I don't
want to get into because I get
demonetised
but you can google it and yeah Stephen
King damn that's not very good anyway
lastly is their leader Rose the
an incredibly beautiful woman that has
gained her name from wearing a
magician's top hat the majority of the
time though we never get confirmation of
her true age we do know that Rose was
born in County Antrim in Ireland where
she was known by her true name Rose
O'Hara like many Irish citizens she
emigrated to America during the
formation of the United States and lived
on the western frontier before being
recruited by the true not members at the
time she is operated with the group
since the 19th century and due to her
amazing abilities quickly rose pun
intended through the ranks to become
their leader Rose is by far the most
powerful out of the group and she is
capable of locating people that possess
the shining across vast distances this
allows her to pick up on a brass stone
someone with even greater psychic
abilities than her and she quickly
becomes Rose's obsession Rose is a cold
and calculating person that hates all of
the humans outside of the true knot and
refers to them as rubes throughout her
life she has tortured countless children
to death and due to her extremely high
IQ and intuitiveness she is able to
quickly create strategies and plans in
her head that will allow her to move
from target to target capturing them in
efficient ways that allow for them to
conserve their energy due to her lack of
emotion towards other living things
Rose plans to kidnap Abra and hold her
in captivity torturing her slowly over a
long period of time in order to form her
force team almost like a milking cow
this is paid lip-service to you in the
film and the reason behind this is
because the true not simply don't
possess enough canisters to contain all
of Rose's steam though she has a sexual
relationship with crow daddy she also
has one with snake by Andy at one point
and it's clear that she's not really
tied down Rose is described by many as
the most beautiful woman that they've
ever seen however for those who possess
the shining they view her as a woman
with an unnaturally wide mouth that has
just one single tooth in it resembling a
walruses tusks after becoming obsessed
with Abra she pulls all of their
resources into tracking her down unaware
that she is being looked after by Danny
the book and ending of the film deficit
Lee do mainly to their ties to their
respective source material and at the
end of the shining book the Overlook
Hotel is destroyed and thus the final
act of the story takes place on the
grounds of where it stood after Abra and
the character go into a psychic standoff
Danny pushes rose off an observation
platform and she falls to her death
breaking her neck upon impact in the
film and the Overlook Danny unleashes
all of the spirits that are housed
within his mind from the location and
they swarm her feasting upon her in the
same way that she preyed on so many
innocents it's an awesome end to an
awesome character and a group of
unforgettable foes that reminds us why
we should not give in to our addictions
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the true knot and which one
of the group is your favorite comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of dr. sleep which you'll be
linked at the end we go over everything
that you need to know about the film
including its plot and the meaning
behind it so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
just want to give a huge thank you for
everyone who took part in the poll I
will be doing another video from that
list but I really hope that you enjoyed
this video if you want to come chat to
me after this and make sure you follow
me on twitter at definition whitey will
head over to my discord server which
should be linked in the description
below those are the best ways to keep up
to date with all the latest videos on
the channel so hopefully I see you over
one of them very soon we're also giving
away a free copy of the marble phase 3
part 1 box on blu-ray which contains
Civil War Doctor Strange homecoming
Ragnarok and more and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on Rose and the true nuts in
the comments section below the winners
gonna be chosen on the 15th of November
and the set will be shipped out from
then to have against the prize so best
of luck to every only takes part this is
the channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]